[Music]
jacob is in carthage texas hi jacob how
are you
man i'm doing great to talk to you dave
and ken hey man what's up
i am 26 my wife and i are in baby steps
four five and six and uh thanks to your
plan and um
because of that i am chasing my dream of
being self-employed cool um
but i'm finding
really finding it really difficult
to balance
working my side hustle because my
full-time job being a dad being a
husband being involved in my church
it's like i'm starving my side hustle
and i'm never giving it
i don't know if i'm ever going to give
it enough to for it to prove itself
what is it what are you doing i don't
know
i make
handmade bass lures that sell for you
know over a hundred dollars a piece
and uh what's your margin on those
uh almost nothing on material yeah
what's the time what does it take to
produce one time wise
as of right now because i'm so small
scale i have like one day that i get to
work on them a week and i can i can turn
one out in a couple hours
okay i haven't really uh there are ways
so if you sell it for 100 bucks your
material cost is almost nothing and it
took two hours you're making 50 an hour
correct yeah the faster i can do it the
more money i can make and i'm and i'm
going to work on investing in some
better production
um practices to help me turn out more
yeah i was going to say i would be
patient on this because you got a lot
going on in your life right now but you
know this is going to be a math equation
you know at some point once you can get
this thing up and going no matter how
long it takes
uh and it replaces your day job income
with where you're at in baby steps four
five and six that's when you do it but
you're eventually gonna have to not only
figure out the production issues but
then train people and slowly grow this
thing so you're gonna have to be patient
regardless that's what i'm kind of
telling you but i wouldn't quit on it
just because you're in a season right
now where you have limited time but i
would say
here's the thing you need to just sit
down with a calendar and choose yeah
what you're going to do with your time
and then be satisfied with that and then
be satisfied with your choice
yeah no guilt i'd be looking for new
employment i mean not necessarily more
time not necessarily so um here's the
thing um
christy wright says in her new book it's
a beautiful line she says balance is not
doing everything equally balance is
doing the right thing at the right time
and for this season
of your life
for the next 12 months
what is the right thing to do with your
time there's not a right or wrong answer
what do you want to do with it
and uh so if you want to be on fewer
church committees and make more bass
lures that's okay
that's that could be the right thing for
you and you just got to lay that out and
decide which one is which
for now and it doesn't be permanent but
for now